la femme de courant perdure mais ses
voisins s'organisent musique jeux de
société même le four de camping à son
utilité il fait plus froid à l'intérieur
qu'à l'extérieur fait que c'est sûr que
ça va être plaisant de retourner dans
son cycle dans son chez soi avec un peu
de chauffage mais somme toute c'est pas
mais oui on a la musique réchauffe le
voisin qui occupe l'appartement
au-dessus du leurre
lui qui commence à trouver le temps long
il n'est pas seul des dizaines de
milliers de foyers sont toujours privés
de courant certains s'impatientent c'est
congelé chez nous là je suis capable
puis faire froid
je vais attendre combien de temps
jusqu'à lundi mon capoter
je sais pas qu'est-ce qui arrive
personne nous dit on les comprend le
passage dans l'une des haltes chaleurs
rendu disponible pour les Québécois
privé d'électricité le ministre de la
Sécurité publique si vous lui rassurant
sur le territoire pas juste à Montréal
c'est Vincent de d'hébergement aussi
peuvent recevoir des gens qui ont besoin
d'une place pour faire de dos là de son
côté Hydro-Québec ne fait qu'aucune
promesse quand au retour définitive du
courant mais répète que les opérations
vont bon train bon nombre d'abonnés
devraient retrouver l'électricité dans
le courant de la soirée mais d'autres
devront encore patienter notre
prédiction c'est que demain en fin de
journée donc dimanche soir vers minuit
on devrait avoir rétabli l'électricité
pour à peu près un million de personnes
donc c'est assez près du
95%. mais sur le terrain les défis sont
considérables
autant que ça à Montréal
si quelque chose il peut avoir peut-être
20 endroits différents sur la même ligne
qui va falloir intervenir l'Ontario n'a
pas été épargné par les intempéries du
mercredi à l'heure actuelle plus de 20
000 foyers risque de passer une autre
nuit dans le noir ici qui me permettra
au Canada Montréal